the nominees for sound editing this year
run the gamut from the cacophony of
battle and black panther and the arena
rock of Bohemian Rhapsody to the quiet
tensions of home and Roma and the
suspenseful silence silence space in
first here are the nominees for
achievement in sound editing black
panther Benjamin a Burt and Steve
Boudica Bohemian Rhapsody John will
Hurst and Mina hearthstone first man
Eileen Lee and Mildred I action Morgan
a quiet place
Ethan Vander Ryan and Eric a doll aroma
Sofia Diaz and skip let's say and the
Oscar goes to Bohemian Rhapsody this is
the first Oscar and nomination for John
Morris
Bohemian Rhapsody is nominated in five
categories tonight including Best
Picture
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Wow that's incredible
we'd like to thank the Academy this is
truly an honor especially in a category
with so many amazing sounding films
working on podium Rhapsody was really
wasn't honor I mean we got to work with
Queen for our day job which was
wonderful if I thank all of Queen and
and the team the full team for the just
for the great music for all support and
yeah especially not to Freddy as well
and quick shout out so many thanks Steph
my kids Nina and I would like to thank
our full Bo rap team all the people who
are here and also everyone back in
London who I know watching right now and
obviously my husband Kevin is up there
my family my kids Noah Lola and Eli my
mom and dad were looking after them
mahmu be home soon
[Applause]